yeah they changed providers on the end
so they put me and they switch me from
paxil to like wellbutrin wellbutrin I
didn't like it it made me feel weird and
then I switched to the batter all in
there
then they searched me something else
they switched me to another thing then
they switched me like zoloft or
something I try to take that and I felt
like I could I didn't I couldn't follow
conversation so this went on for like 3
months finally I just said you know what
[ __ ] it I'm not gonna take it anymore
I'm just gonna see what happens yeah and
then I've been dealing with it ever ever
since then I was telling my telling
Stacy oh you're still taking those meds
I'll take anything that's good you
shouldn't that's just [ __ ] it's just
so [ __ ] so bad for you yeah but
here's the difference where before when
I was taking paxil everything was okay
I'm okay yeah that's good
my house burned down oh man that's a
home it was hurt I mean just didn't
affect me everybody should say nothing
bothers you you don't you know I didn't
obsess I'm here soon right because I was
in a zombie but it levels you off I felt
okay and now this is well soon now the
difference is I wake up at 5 in the
morning my alarm goes off but I don't
get out of bed till about 5:15 5:20
because I spent about 15 or 20 minutes
tell him myself
it's gonna be okay Kim my now I'm prison
when I was in prison it was ten times
worse I would lay in bed not go oh my
god I'm still in prison
I'd be like it's gonna be okay it's
gonna be okay and you know I would lay
in bed my first thought was honestly how
much dental floss do I have to buy to
weave a rope to kill myself in the
bathroom at two o'clock in the morning
because that's when you can do it
there's a pole over the handicap stall
that's high enough that you can actually
you could actually hang yourself and
you'd be done it's the only real spot to
do it I mean it is that bad in the
mornings so I was we like knew how much
dental floss to have to buy and I would
sit there like it's not rational what
are you thinking and I was like I can't
do this I can't do that and you just go
over into your head and go over and go
over it and then I said just get some
coffee
it's okay it's okay okay it's gonna be
okay it's gonna get some coffee just get
some coffee concer so I get myself out
of bed and I just go just just get some
coffee you can always do this just get
your coffee get some coffee
you feel a little bit better and it
still is like I can't do this I can't do
this is a nice thing no I got to meet so
and so today
I get dressed and then I go to library
I'd work with somebody or I'd write
something and then buy by the time
recall came around where they call you
back to the unit I ten o'clock I'd be
like it's okay it's okay you can do it
you can get through the day you can get
through the day this is the
conversations going in my [ __ ] while
I'm talking you this is what's going on
in the back of my head you can do this
you can do this you can do this you can
it's gonna be okay it's gonna stop
thinking like that stop thinking that's
not rational and so by the time lunch
comes I mean in lunch it's okay this is
good they got apple pie I like apple pie
you're fine tonight they're gonna have
fried chicken they make good fried
chicken here it's good it's okay it's
okay by two or three o'clock you're like
I'll feel okay I can do this I can I can
I'm okay mm-hmm
by five o'clock or six o'clock when I'm
eating I'm like it's good you're locked
up some good guys you like Greg Greg's a
cool guy Jimmy's all right he always
makes me laugh you know by eight o'clock
you're there they got them they got the
movie on the night it's good I love that
much James Bond it's great by nine
o'clock you're thinking things are going
good I got this into courts this is
happening so-and-so is doing this I
might be able to make it out by 10
o'clock I'm kicking ass I'm getting out
of this [ __ ] place I'm gonna [ __ ]
hit the streets I'm gonna write these
[ __ ] stories everything's gonna be
[ __ ] amazing I'm gonna sell [ __ ]
options I'm gonna [ __ ] kick ass I'm
gonna be driving a [ __ ] Ferrari I'm
gonna be riding at 8:22 you're like
amazing when I get out gonna bar they're
gonna [ __ ] die and by the next
morning it was how much [ __ ] dental
floss do I have to buy every day this
went on the whole [ __ ] time I was
telling Stacey do a day about it and she
goes Austin she just well but you don't
think that anymore and I went oh I still
have lay in bed till 5:00 5:15 5:20
telling myself it's okay I'm not
thinking about getting dental floss oh
I'm thinking does Stacey have a gun in
the house they wouldn't let her just for
a brief second but I gotta see a
psychiatrist right mm-hmm
a lot of people see psychiatrists I mean
that's a look I got so no more thing I
got on court-ordered
[ __ ] psychiatrist I'm saying a lot of
people a lot of really successful people
use psychiatrists now is like a weekly
ritual that's because that's good for
your mental health I guess it's okay now
to talk about like people people do that
no it's a lot more popular now I mean
yeah well mine's court-ordered so yeah
so but it's good like you know it's good
for you should do it even if it wasn't
court-ordered I guess do you know it's
quite see a psychiatrist
[ __ ] yeah bro listen I if I could get to
that story on here you can't believe
it's cool to say shot myself it was not
cool